discounts everywhere and yet everything
seems more expensive than it used to be
a cost of living crisis means households
are tightening their belts this year
so while the queues may look impressive
the tussle for bargains frantic
the Boxing Day Sale has been a more
muted Affair than usual this year I'm a
regular visitor and I'm really surprised
at how quiet it is only got two bags
normally I would come out with eight or
ten bags I only got two bags the sales
all online anyway this year and a lot of
cells were beforehand we kind of came
knewing what we were going to get in
advance the rise of online shopping has
been chipping away at the High Street
for several years now
But Rising household costs and
widespread transport strikes are adding
to the strain
across all UK retail destinations
footfall by lunchtime on boxing day was
down almost a third compared with 2019
before the pandemic hit
all parts of the UK recorded a drop in
footfall but turnout was still up by
half compared to last year when the
Omicron variant caused large swathes of
the country to stay at home if I were a
retailer I'd be saying these results
today are encouraging because what they
demonstrate is they Desire by consumers
to want a shop in store you know any
chance they get they'll go into store
and enjoy it the Gap from here from now
to 2019 is a big one and that is
therefore a marker and a challenge and I
would really say that that is a warning
sign of things to come
it's a pretty mild December afternoon
here perfect for a spot of boxing day
shopping but it's getting increasingly
difficult to tempt people out onto the
High Street after counting the cost of
rising bills households haven't got
quite as much money to spend in the
sales this year
the Christmas trading period is crunch
time for retailers
and while the tills are still ringing on
boxing day
businesses know there may be quieter
days ahead
gurpreet no one Sky News